what's up guys we are in Florida right
now I'm here with my sister and my
girlfriend and my dad knows somebody
who's pretty influential here who owns a
six point five million dollar apartment
it is actually listed as three point
seven million dollars now because I
guess after I went to visit it got
cheaper but before he takes it off the
market he's gonna let us explore it make
sure that everyone sees this a car that
you're pulling up into the six point
five million dollar apartment and so we
are going to be checking out the town
suite at the Trump Royale now a town
suite is above a penthouse and this town
suite is actually to town Suites
combined so it is the top two floors fun
fact
Trump actually doesn't own the building
they just pay for the name you have to
have a key to get to the town suite
because it goes past all of the regular
floors the penthouse is and then takes
you straight to the apartment
and you feel like you've made it
anything to add some people up right so
we're going to try this again with my
sister instead because Sabrina's
reactions were so no we tried it again
but my sister's reaction wasn't much
better
[Music]
yeah the feud is insane and if you look
around there's a news everywhere so it's
a few in front of you view behind you
the best view myself got this cool
little mirror if you don't want to look
at yourself having a bad day you just
close this thing and you're like I'm not
checking myself out today I'm taking a
pee real estate so then we got a piano
like that about my sister who's
impressed me out there and make sure to
take us through the class because this
is we're going to play overall
[Music]
this right here I don't know what this
is but it looks expensive
Cavalli roberto cavalli floors so this
is the first view beautiful it's amazing
the ocean is huge so I really love to
cook and something I spend most of my
days doing when I'm not working and this
kitchen is safe there's two full ovens
so I don't know why you would ever need
two full ovens but I guess if you have
an amazing apartment like this you're
gonna have huge parties you're getting
you to cook a lot so one and two two
refrigerators
to store food and advice if you don't
live in this home you know how valuable
counter spaces and this one has so much
[Music]
okay so now this is the second you look
at this beauty the other side of the
building that is water not sure what
kind of water that is like I don't know
some sort of river that's the ocean over
there you're chilling out here right I
mean someone's cooking or whatever you
know if you have enough money you have
some Butler or something or some chefs
they could just pass the food right here
and you just hand out my sister the
bathrooms are so I'm going to this
bathroom this is Roberto Cavalli here
and this looks like a very fancy sink so
I'm going to see if it feels more fancy
like I don't know if washing your hands
and a fancy saying is any fancier
[Music]
exactly one floor the owner told us that
the elevator only uses air technology so
it's you literally fly it just makes you
fly somehow I'm gonna try it yep trying
out this elevator
those of you oh gosh
[Applause]
[Music]
that's terrifying just like a roller
coaster all right Eric let's speed it up
the apartment is 4,300 square feet it's
got four bedrooms and four and a half
bathrooms there's a lot to cover the
room on the first floor is breathtaking
because one of the walls is just a
window so the view is incredible
bouncy indeed let's check out the
bathroom
you can press 15 minutes five minutes
Eric four hours of perfect timing for
you good joke haha anyway the bathroom
was super fancy so fancy we actually
couldn't figure out how the mirror works
or is it do they just make it look like
a ring light three middle-class people
try to figure out how expensive mirrors
work after giving up on the mirror we
went upstairs to check out the other
three bedrooms the first room we saw had
a very nice view it was very spacious it
also had a fancy bathroom with bidets
and fancy lights and roberto cavalli
walls in the shower and a showerhead
that was so fancy we again had no idea
how to use it it took us a couple
minutes then then we figured it out and
it was good after showering we went to
check out the view and guess what it was
freakin amazing
again just awesome what can I say and
there was a jacuzzi I mean come on the
next bedroom just had giant closets I
don't know how you would even reach
anything at the top but great closets
huge they were huge closets that was
terrible this bathroom had even more
Roberto Cavalli designs and the master
bedroom Wow
I don't even know what this little area
is maybe it's if you like changing like
while sitting on a cubby any it doesn't
matter it that room is just giant and
the view is just all view there's so
much space the bed is enormous it just
feels amazing and then there's a Jacuzzi
right outside and then you just pull
these doors open and you walk outside
onto your balcony and you just feel
incredible like Zeus the master bathroom
is also very impressive there is a
shower that's very spacious also a
personal jacuzzi that I've never seen
before and
magical bidet that automatically opens
sprays water and there were so many
buttons I had to try it
Oh going up my butt the closet was so
big it could easily fit my five outfits
so that's a plus that's not even a joke
I live in a closet so this has been
surreal so what did you think of the
apartment I thought it is incredible
I've never seen anything like this it's
definitely nothing like we've ever lived
in before it's remarkable place was
absolutely amazing and I want nothing
less okay well you're getting a lot less
if you want my girlfriend to be happy
please share this video so that I don't
get fired and can maybe afford something
better than a closet or buy this amazing
apartment so that you can see the huge
ocean all the time and then invite me
and my girlfriend over
[Music]
you
[Music]